everything that you get
comes at a cost there's nothing for free
and the only question is is the cost
worth it people who've done extremely
well the question is at what cost what
we're talking about is the desire to
have without paying for it which is I
want this but I'm not willing to pay the
cost right so for example working really
hard to get something I want to achieve
this the cost is I'm gonna have a couple
sleepless nights I'm going to work a
little harder I'm going to miss out on
some social events it might be a little
bit exhausted now and then but for me
that's worth the cost
because of what I'm trying to accomplish
and so I think what we're seeing is a
misunderstanding of the cost of equation
because ain't nothing for free